oh it's me judge asked who picked this
music of course
more warning signs democrats are headed
for some colossal losses this november
van jones is just the latest liberal to
sound the alarm
when you over promise so much in the
beginning of the year and you're
undelivering at the end of the year and
don't forget bill back better etcetera
you suddenly wind up with a
disappointment factor plus inflation you
got to signal the people that the people
that brought you to the dance young
people and black folks are going to get
something out of the government or
people are not going to want to vote so
what's the white house's solution to
prevent this disaster well more cowbell
more of the deeply unpopular 79-year-old
commander in chief more joe biden an
advisor tells fox news biden will ramp
up campaign appearances for democrats
while pushing his agenda greg i don't
want to be petty i think these examples
i'm about to give you are relevant
incapable of saying the word kleptocracy
ushered by the easter bunny told when to
wave or sit by jill biden
can it really be that the public needs
more joe biden you don't understand man
the kids gen z they love joe they love
joe he is so edgy it's hip and edgy to
be mindless right now they love him they
love him they love him cnn i gotta hand
it to him and van jones has always been
a straight shooter
saying that the daily lives of black
americans have gotten worse under joe so
compared to who
trump which means they were better off
under trump which is what trump was
saying do you remember that when he used
to say what do you got to lose what do
you got to lose people forgot he was he
was lampooned for that he was basically
saying that the democratic party relies
on blacks to win and then they give them
the shaft and all that blacks really
want is what everybody else wants which
is like a good economy great jobs it's
the problem with the democratic party
they have and why blacks i think should
be pissed
they assume that skin color equates
wokism because you're part of an
identity group then you should also buy
into everything that the white leftist
is into the white progressive that you
should be into defunding the cops right
or that maybe you know rioting is just a
form of more aerobic protests you know
it was like all the all the all the
progressive stuff that is spewed from
the antifa whites is supposed to be
embraced by blacks no they live the same
day-to-day reality as millions of other
people that means they're upset by
inflation they are really upset by crime
because oftentimes they live in areas
where they become victims of crime and
they do care about the border because
that affects jobs so i think what
happened is they they just assume that
blacks think differently about stuff
that's racist
well harold to that point the numbers
greg is referring to first of all 41
approval rating overall but if you dig
into it with minorities black voters and
also with the young voters
it's even worse it's getting really bad
as you slice and dice the electorate
i agree with everything greg said thank
you and i think that democrats
republicans are like everyone in
politics
should understand more and more
that every voting bloc there's some
common denominators people want safe
neighborhoods
people want the best prices lowest
prices for things that they need they're
indispensable goods
people want a border that is protected
and i got to tell you the issue of
education which for a long time when i
was in politics was an
economic issue has become a cultural
issue in many ways because of some of
the fights and battles that are
happening in classrooms and i think that
democrats should be very careful to to
to not stereotype and generalize and
believe that every black parent is going
to agree with some of the things that
have been
assigned to those who who appear to be
woke in our country uh black parents
want their kids to learn there's certain
things we can debate if we have things
in the classroom that unsettle students
we shouldn't make students feel bad
about themselves but we should tell the
truth about our history and those things
but
democrats listen closely to what greg
said and listen closely uh to what van
jones and more importantly listen to
those numbers african-americans are
approve of president biden 67 down from
20 points right now i'm not we're
slightly different with greg on the
donald trump thing but one thing is for
certain those words resonate and what
what what donald trump was saying uh
there's an element of truth uh that some
democrats believed i didn't vote for
donald trump but there were a number
there were a number of african-americans
who did
these numbers are alarming as we head
into a season where the
democrats are on the ballot in the house
and the senate so but katie i'm looking
at this economy immigration foreign
policy inflation crime gasoline what do
you have to brag about information i
know that's the thing i mean republicans
are loving this the nrc the nrcc the rnc
they're happy with joe biden going out
and talking about the contrast between
republicans and the biden administration
because joe biden's just going to talk
about how they're terrible and he may
say you're not black if you don't
believe in his policies
and republicans have plans to offer in
sweden states especially when it comes
to these issues that you just listed off
and we've gone from
republicans looking like they're going
to take the house to looking like
they're going to take the house and the
senate you said a year ago that the
senate would have been a really tough
draw well it's looking more and more
that republicans are going to take it
based on being focused on those issues
well the white house continues to be in
this woke bubble where they're sending
the president out to talk about things
that people quite frankly aren't really
interested in when it comes to theory
and all that kind of stuff they want to
talk about issues that affect their
daily life but even beyond the issues
judge i don't know how they convince
themselves that biden is the messenger
that every democrat needs
you know biden is underwater in 40
states right now the question that i
have is who's going to ask biden to join
them to go out in the public i mean the
guy who can't read a teleprompter
straight who says i'm not worried about
a of recession and
i thought i'm worried about a recession
i mean you know the guy doesn't have a
message that is that makes any sense and
you know so sending him out is not the
smartest thing to do but i also think
that in line with one of the things that
that harold was saying is you've got
these political operatives on the left
and they are trying to convince people
that it's a smart thing to
you know to to impinge upon free speech
because they're saying that the
especially this woman nina jankovitz or
whatever her name is that first
amendment
marginalizes people of color
okay so they trying to convince them
that if you're a person of color we're
going to take care of you we're going to
help you and they're just trying to move
those numbers up but the bottom line is
everybody wants the same thing to be
able to feed their family to be safe and
secure and not have to worry about
issues that you know they didn't have to
worry about two and a half years ago
you're absolutely right i think the
quote was free speech absolutists are a
threat to marginalized communities yeah
crazy everything's racist of course
including border security
that idea is an unhinged liberal talking
point we share with you next hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now